everybody's talking about the democratic
convention day one and michelle obama in
particular and that's where we begin
today
the democrats all out attack on
president trump at their national
convention
as they presented their vision of the
country's future on day one a series of
speakers including
bernie sanders and amy klobuchar
characterized the president as a failed
and dangerous leader and they presented
joe biden as a candidate with the
character and experience
the nation needs right now and one of
those speakers former first lady
michelle obama took direct aim at the
president
and the chaos she says he has created
during a speech that focused on themes
of unity
our ed o'keefe is in washington for us
ed this was a different kind of
convention
and this was a different tone for
michelle obama sure is tony good morning
mrs obama has mostly stayed out of
partisan politics since leaving the
white house
but in remarks that were taped before
kamala harris was chosen as joe biden's
running mate she made clear
is her support for him is personal and
she took on president trump
like never before if you think
things cannot possibly get worse trust
me
they can and they will if we don't make
a change
former first lady michelle obama said
she was speaking out in order to deliver
the cold
hard truth donald trump is the wrong
president for our country he has had
more than enough time to prove that he
can do the job but he
is clearly in over his head he cannot
meet this moment
he simply cannot be who we need him to
be
for us it is what it is
that phrase it is what it is was a knock
on president trump's recent reaction to
the number of daily us deaths
due to coronavirus they are dying that's
true
and you have it is what it is but that
doesn't mean we aren't doing everything
we can
the former first lady said that after
eight years in the white house
she knows firsthand the challenges of
the presidency
the job is hard it requires
clear-headed judgment a mastery of
complex and competing issues
a devotion to facts and history a moral
compass
and an ability to listen and she
believes biden
will guide the country forward he is a
profoundly
decent man guided by faith
he was a terrific vice president he
knows what it takes to rescue an economy
beat back a pandemic and lead our
country
biden's top primary rival senator bernie
sanders also slammed mr trump's response
to the pandemic
nero fiddled while rome burned
trump golfs and he called on supporters
to help defeat the president
to everyone who supported other
candidates in the primary
and to those who may have voted for
donald trump in the last election
the future of our democracy is at stake
the future of our economy is at stake
the future of our planet is at stake
also last night former ohio governor
john kasich was one of four republicans
invited to try convincing
other gop voters to switch sides i'm
sure there are republicans and
independents who couldn't imagine
crossing over to support a democrat
they fear joe may turn sharp left and
leave them behind
i don't believe that an ordinary
american spoke out
enough is enough including kristin
orkizza
who lost her father to coronavirus my
dad was a healthy
65 year old his only pre-existing
condition
was trusting donald trump and for that
he paid with his life
and the brothers of george floyd let's
make sure
we never stop saying their names
as democrats put up a united front they
also recalled their historically large
and diverse primary season unity isn't
about settling
it's about striving for something more
so as if on cue the president has just
tweeted his response to mrs obama's
speech saying in person quote
somebody please explain to michelle
obama that donald j trump
would not be here in the beautiful white
house if it weren't for the job
done by your husband barack obama look
this virtual convention it continues
tonight it
looks a lot like big brother crossed
with american idol into jerry lewis
telethon
sleekly produced interviews and
confessionals and music videos
and traditional political speeches it
continues tonight with two political
survivors former presidents carter and
clinton
and joe biden's wife jill anthony i'm
glad you mentioned the jerry lewis
telethon ed i remember it well thanks